a reduced annual session of the Eastern
European parliamentary assembly took
place in Brussels on the same day as
multiple terror attacks Brooke carnage
and tragedy to the capital that we are
all files Uranus is a forum to promote
greater partnership across areas ranging
from foreign affairs education and the
economy at this year's meeting a
resolution cordon Russia to immediately
release the Ukrainian pilot gnarly
shevchenko who was sentenced on Tuesday
to 22 years in jail we do not recognize
this so-called verdict as a legitimate
one this was a farce and we will
continue to demand the unconditional
release of nadia savchenko from the
prison across the two days members also
had meetings with affiliated political
groups I know what is the most important
issue your independence and Russia a
finish and I'm always ready to help
another issue for the MEP was
strengthening Europe's energy security
vibe partnership with Eastern neighbors
they are very important for us not only
because as energy sources in this
countries but also as shown in the roads
total opinion we cannot develop out the
economy cannot be competitive without
energy supply security of energy supply
and affordable prices but due to the
terror threat level in Brussels the
Uranus Parliamentary Assembly came to an
abrupt end